might as well let this uh get started
and uh Pamela Geller please come up
and thank you and thank you all for
being here it gives me hope when I see
people come out that might not
ordinarily come at but perhaps sees the
dangerous Seas ahead and um I know this
is an evening about Israel and I want to
talk about Obama and Israel and I'm not
going to talk long uh but the book is
the post American presidency the Obama
Administration of war in America and
I've been asked did you say War to be
provocative and I said you ought to be
accurate uh even yesterday with the
Arizona ruling and everybody's talking
about that it was a victory for Obama it
was a defeat for the American people it
was an attack on America uh I don't
believe that Obama cares about the
borders he's an
internationalist he is an international
internationalist who believes in Mass
immigration uh the law itself mimicked
federal law what is the president of the
United States doing suing the American
people I ask
you I use the word post American because
he is working towards a world where
America is not a
superpow or the moral Authority that
she's just one of many socialist Nations
when asked in Europe if he believed in
American exceptionalism he said I
believe in it as much as I believe in
British exceptionalism French
exceptionalism which means no I don't
believe this no nobody's
exceptional and what's critical and what
is such a key point is because what is
American
[Music]
exceptionalism it is individual
exceptionalism that's what it is and
that's the basic founding principle of
this great nation individual rights
everything that we
became everything that we became that we
achieve that was heroic was a logical
consequence of fidelity to that very
princip
before the election I had been
researching this book for 3 years I he
came on my radar screen in late 2007 and
I was very troubled by his allegiances
his alliances I was troubled by his
background um he grew up from the age 6
to 12 in the streets of Indonesia he was
listed on his school records as a Muslim
now don't start with me I'm just saying
it was there was deception during the
campaign you weren't allowed to talk
about it not only were you not not
allowed to talk about it but anyone that
used his middle name was a racist
islamophobic anti-muslim
bot he became president and the very
first interview he gave was to Al Arabia
television where he announced himself to
me Barack Hussein
Obama with proud as punch that he had a
Muslim family members his grandmother
who was a Christian in 20 8 was now a
Muslim in 2009 now why I find this
troubling is because he was deceitful
about it he lied I find it troubling
because we know from the study of Islam
that Islamic anti-Semitism is in the
very DNA of that ideology we know
because every friend every Alliance
every Association he has is rapidly
anti-semitic his friend Rashid KH who
was a member of the PLO in the 70s when
it was the most humous terrorist group
in the world now there's a lot of
competition because we're in a modern
era of the modern Savage but at the time
he was a member rashed K and Obama B had
his children Obama when he sat on the
tides the woods the woods Foundation
along with terce Bill a gave 40,000 and
30,000 respectively to uh KH
Rashid and what's most troubling is that
the day before yesterday uh Rashid
announced that he was going to find he's
raising money for another Jihad warship
flotilla which is uh an act of war
against the Jewish people but I didn't
get to the best plot yet the name of the
flotilla is The Audacity Of
Hope and I don't how you know what I
mean the thing is he couldn't have done
that without the imperato of Obama and
just as the locker B bom when was
released which was shocking shocking
this was the first terrorist really
large terrorist attack on America and
they release they released this mass
murderer he says he doesn't know about
it but it comes out in the British papus
two days ago that he signed off on it of
course he signed off and there's no way
they would have released that guy now
before I go to the candidates cuz I know
they're just chomping at the bit and
soon they'll be angle biting okay I just
want to go I just want to if I might go
just one after another Ratatat like a
machine gun some of the things Obama has
done in concern concerning Israel as you
know you must have some seen the UK
prime minister in Turkey uh yesterday uh
denouncing Israel for defending herself
now that we you saw that in black and
white you saw those videos now if I do
one more time that it was humanitarian
Aid I'm going to tell you something I
have friends that go to Gaza and and I
think Gaza has an obesity
[Music]
problem it's it's it's teaming with food
and new shopping malls and swimming
pools meanwhile they're starving to
death in Dar and in the and nobody talks
about any of this but it's a
humanitarian crisis they have every
right to stop those arms that are going
into that state and what people don't
understand
what people don't understand is even if
you're not like you don't like Jewish
people the thing is is that Israel
really is on the front line of the
global Jihad she absorbs so much
activity if Israel wasn't there you have
no idea the amount of Islamic Terror
that would be Unleashed on this world
it's like she's the mop-up girl and you
keep she's Cinderella and you keep
kicking her in the head she's critical
to our national security and we have
seen time and time again that this is a
pro Islam
president appro he he went to Alazar
University the leading Islamic
University in Egypt fine made a speech
always speaks to the um not to French
Muslims or British Muslims always to the
worldwide Muslim Community so he's
buying right into that whole you know
Islamic Uma Global Jihad
thing and he says that the violation of
women's rights in in the Muslim world is
just as bad in America oh
really he he said he said we have
I mean 96% of the girls in Egypt have
been
cized honor killings women of property
they're subjugated they have to walk
around in cloth carpin and say they like
it and he equates that he says he's
going to make America safe for women to
wear the hijab who stops them but
meanwhile they don't want to weab and I
know they right to me like griffa Barry
when she left Ohio the Christian convert
and was doged chased across the country
to bring her back an a student no drugs
no boys virin they're chasing this
little girl because she converted out of
Islam you girls are running away from
home selling their bodies doing drugs
nobody's looking for
that think about it let's think about it
put your politics aside let's think
rationally we have to start to think
just like I can't say to this guy look
go to the gym for me I want I want to
firm up my butts he can't do that for me
you can't let people think for you you
have to learn you have to first learn
everything I will tell you that Obama is
in secret talks with
Hamas is the Muslim Brotherhood just
like the Muslim American society in this
country is the Muslim Brotherhood and
armor of the Muslim Brotherhood that's
not my opinion it was proven in evidence
in ter the terror trial the Holy Land
trial care the Council of American
Islamic relations in this country is the
Muslim Brotherhood meanwhile they are
the go-to guys for the media the Imam
behind the Ford hood Jihadi behind the
Time Square bomber behind the Christmas
Day bomber behind the 911 Muslim
terrorists Ori was the go to Iman by the
media right after 911 they don't tell
you that I can tell you I went to
Florida boa because Sarah s was good
told all the grandmas all the Bubbies
that they have to vote for Obama so I
went down there to boa and I was yelling
in boa par and I was Ling every single
he doesn't have one normal friend not
one Reverend Wright Titus th with faran
faran Titus SE with Gaddafi Gaddafi
raised money for
him again another
thing I broke the story of the
contributions from Gaza he received tens
of thousands of dollars in contributions
from Gaza a Hamas controlled area I
broke that story media wouldn't touch it
or I broke the story of him and reala
odinga odinga in Kenya a Kenya who was
that's our Ally kabaki is our Ally he
was run against them he signed a memor
memorandum of understanding with the
Muslims to impose Sharia law should he
win when he didn't win they were they
were they were rioting through the
streets burning churches slicing people
to bits so they gave him the position of
prime minister and what do we doing now
your taxpayer dollars have to spend $23
million to change the constitution in
Kenya to impose Sharia law do you know
that I am telling you that you have you
cannot take an equival position on
Israel he is looking to make a deal with
head he is an American Jews are looking
the other way he said that he's going to
stop vetoing resolutions against Israel
in the UN this is why he's seeing this
enormous sort of rise in anti-Semitism
across the world because you know what
the most benevolent policeman this
humankind has ever seen has walked off
the
beat we are watching this man preside
over the decline of America aiding and
eding the decline of America by
bankrupting this nation by relinquishing
American sovereignty in the world
when was the world ever safer than after
America the force of good won the war
against the Nazis I ask you you think
that was an accident listen he's anti
platonic Plato said that the world is a
chaotic place it was chaos and that
peace was a parentheses it's true
because war is part of our DNA like
eating and sleeping and loving I'm sorry
but it's a fact whether you like it or
not he thinks he can solder in and give
his million dollarars SM and was going
to be like oh
okay buddy let's roast some marshmallows
around the campfire it's not going to
happen they're going to they have their
interests and they're going to take
advantage of their interests and
certainly when you have a president who
is turning my allies into enemies and
aligning with our enemies we're in
trouble and I'm going to tell you one
thing first year was Healthcare energy
and education that was what you didn't
see anything foreign policy that was
first year he ran from National self
care you're going to see him run through
energy August 6th Captain tax you're
going to see it and he's going to use
the gulf so Mis handled so is elately M
handled any other president would have
established a war room within 48 hours
and the biggest brains in the world
solving this problem instead he turned
down help from the Netherlands who said
we can clean it up he turned down help
from our allies why why is the media
reporting on it the media filed Freedom
of Information at requests to take
pictures of the bodies during Katrina
but then not allowed down there to take
pictures and Katrina as terrible as it
was was you could fix it this is keeps
ining this damages for decades they're
wiping out whole communities whole
Industries the nation is in trouble and
I'm not overstating it and I'm telling
you I'm hoping that we can look to these
men this
woman we can look to these true
but we we will not we will not judge men
or women by their sex or their race
because let me tell you something
America was the best reputation of
racist theories in the history of man
because men from all colors and all
Creeds came to this country and made
enormous success which would never
happened in their control ridden uh
lands it never would have happened so
when they say that you're racist
remember it's to shut you up that's the
objective and no president has ever so
deceived a Division I me he's creating
racism where where is none I've spoken a
teap parties I've been to tea parties I
have not seen one racist there they say
well you know there was a guy with a
sign that guy with a sign was ay planned
or they take a picture of a kid he's
holding a sign like this they cut off a
sign it looks like he's giving the
Hitler salute this is what they do this
is how dirty it is they're smearing and
liing millions of Americans because when
they were doing when we painting bush
with a r you know I went to those
rallies and that's where I met Dan Dan
Maloney always countering always Dan
Maloney is here pamel
Hall we we saw this we counted this the
most vile invective but you know what
desent is the highest form of perotis
and it was good and now they're going to
criminalize what we're doing they're
going to criminalize speech hate what
I'm doing now is hate speech you think
it's not happening for the first time in
US history the United States of America
signed a resolution at the UN to
restrict Free Speech did you know that
not to defame Islam and if you think it
doesn't matter remember any treaty the
United States signed supersede the
Constitution do you like your guns I
know I like mine you like your guns they
pass a small Arm Street in the UN
they're going to take it away you watch
you will not believe your eyes if we
don't remove his hammer his hammer he
has a hammer it's the Congress in
November
I see the
[Applause]